indigenous Ecuadorians continue
converging on the capital Quito to give
their president in ultimatum either
repeal highly unpopular austerity
measures or get out they say we've come
from the middle of Ecuador to reject
this unpopular government that's taken
measures dictated by the IMF president
Lenin Moreno says he's open to dialogue
but insists he can't back out of his
commitment to reduce the fiscal debt by
eliminating fuel subsidies something
he'd vowed never to do when he took
office the demonstrators were further
angered when they found out that
President Madero had moved the executive
branch overnight to the coastal city of
Guayaquil for hours and well into the
night protesters tried without success
to overcome riot police
in an attempt to surround the
presidential palace and national
assembly some of the indigenous leaders
are asking them to move away put their
lives at risk and to march to another
part of the city but they're angry they
say they are not going to budge that
they haven't walked so far to turn back
now
the leader of the National Confederation
of indigenous people told Al Jazeera
there would be no dialogue until
President would enter returns to Quito
and repeals the decree if Moreno doesn't
want to administer this country with the
social chaos where there's no social
justice no freedom better he lived the
country for ever to join that other
fidgety from justice ex-president Correa
they can live together Moreno says the
worst unrest in more than a decade in
this country is being orchestrated by
his former boss and now his worst enemy
former President Rafael Correa who lives
in self-imposed exile in Brussels
Correa denies he's pulling the strings
but he doesn't hide his political
ambitions including the possibility of
returning home to run for Vice President
he knows either Moreno resigns or he
asks for early elections which will be
the constitutional and democratic way to
overcome this grave situation that
scenario may be premature despite the
mounting social unrest and political
intrigue here but then again Ecuador has
a very long history of presidents being
forced out before their term is up you
see in human al Jazeera Quito
[Applause]